foreign
Rebecca is with us in Louisville hi
Rebecca welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave how are you great what's up
um I really really would love your
advice
um my husband I recently just found out
that he committed what you call
Financial infidelity and I I don't know
honestly what to do at this point
okay so he's been lying to you about
money
about what yes because he didn't tell me
that he was spending it okay what did he
spend it on what how much he spent about
two grand on his credit card for like
just stupid stuff like sports equipment
hunting equipment and like golf clubs
okay and it's a big deal because we're
on baby step number two
and we're trying very hard to get out of
that right now and I we just paid off
his credit card this month and I I just
can't believe that he just did that and
and I never would have found out if I
hadn't gone and checked the Amazon
receipts
do those receipts match up you didn't
notice uh golf clubs in the house
well that was how I found out I came
home from work and I saw a huge box and
I saw that there was golf clubs in the
box and then I was like so it's not
really good at lying
no he's not
and listen when you're saying that we
are working so hard to get out of debt
you're not accurate you are he is not
he is living his best life
a note
okay
well I stick to the budget and I we're
going through Financial Peace University
we got married six months ago and that
was when we really found Dave like your
book and Total Money Makeover and I read
it in like a day and he's still halfway
through the book and we watch Financial
abuse university and he tries to fast
forward through half of it and I mean
your name unfortunately is now a cuss
word in our house and I never meant for
that to happen so I'm sorry Dave can
handle it
um let's get let's get beneath that
there's other things that have happened
in this last six months that are tearing
you up what else
all right I just feel like
he is like like I just feel like the
trust has been broken and I feel like
he's really angry and going through
something and whenever I try to talk to
him about it like he gets angry again
and defensive and uh just usually ends
up in him yelling and huffing and
puffing and I I don't know like I
thought I mean most the time I were
really good except like whenever he just
gets mad and I don't know if it's the
shame because all the debt is from him
I think it's I'm confident there's shame
there but there's something different
and that is
he didn't fully understand how much his
life would change when his world went
from all about whatever he wants
whenever he wants it to building a new
life with somebody else that we are
going to both sacrifice for and this is
called being an adult it's gonna be in a
grown-up it's called having character he
doesn't have that
he's a child trapped in a man's body
they got a credit card that can just buy
whatever he wants
and he can keep his wife happy by
letting her run around with her little
plan
well he goes and buys whatever he wants
that's the child's entitlement
and so the pro the challenge I hear
folks make at this stage
is you want to make it about the money
and I want you to hear me say there are
bigger fractures in the in the
foundation of your marriage
that need to be addressed
100 I have not a doubt in my mind no I
don't think you can y'all can I think he
can and you can together yeah y'all can
yeah but you can't you've been trying to
fix everything by yourself so far money
yeah to the counseling couple counseling
four in the past and then go without It
Go without him go without him
I'm going to counseling to figure out if
this marriage can be saved
I wish you would go with me
but if you won't I'm going anyway
and then your counselor will give you
words and help you work through the
decisions of whether this makes it or
not
but you cannot buy yourself make a
marriage
that thus the definition of a marriage
I want you to remember this on the same
page I want you to remember this on the
same page on anything yeah nothing yeah
behavior is a language
and if you say what Dave said verbatim
I'm going to see if our marriage can be
saved
I hope you'll go I hope you'll go with
me and he goes yeah I'm going golfing
behavior is a language he is telling you
loud and clear what he thinks he's done
that's what that means
no but go but go anyway go anyway of
course maybe your counselor can give you
some if you've got a good therapist that
has a backbone that can uh give you
language to begin to draw this draw him
into a uh a bigger and better dream uh
of what this marriage can be or you know
draw it to a close one of the two will
happen because one of those two is going
to happen anyway but all we're trying to
do is give you the tools to do it with
some uh wisdom and before there's a
house and kids and the whole thing
sideways and also let me give you a
little bit of peace
it is other than the sun coming up every
day couples who have been recently
married in the first six months
experience whoa
didn't expect that didn't see that now
they don't experience outright lying all
the time like you are but every couple
goes through six month hiccups like I
didn't think this was gonna be like this
I didn't think it was going to feel like
this and so let's let's um pretend he
doesn't have the tools
to I didn't know how to decide how to be
a grown-up and not act like a child
great he needs to go to counseling and
learn some tools
because he doesn't know how yeah
and you can model what that looks like
by going this is childish and selfish
behavior on this part and I'm sorry that
you got dragged in it and sometimes
women do that sometimes men do it at all
ages it's not an age thing it's not a
guy thing it's not a gal thing and I'm
not even positive to be honest with you
that he was lying to you
I think he just did whatever he wanted
to do and it wasn't like he was sneaking
around the golf clubs were put on your
front porch
so this isn't like he had some pattern
of financial infidelity is when you have
a pattern of lying that is a broken
trust and I don't think that the I think
the only trust that he was going to
follow this plan was in your mind
I don't think this guy ever signed up
for the trip you took him on
well I thought he was maybe blind
because we have a budget and he has a
budget of pocket money and he put on
there like well then he did lie to you
on that he broke it he broke his
contract he said I'm not going to spend
any more than x and I did whatever I
wanted to do because that's all
five-year-olds say I deserved it
way
five-year-olds in congressman
[Music]
the Ramsay show